the position that America is in our
position in the world the growing gap
between the rich and the poor all these
things create tension and people want an
answer and unfortunately it's very hard
to have an answer when government is
completely divided people in Washington
can't govern because they're divided
between Republicans and Democrats
conservatives and liberals religious
fundamentalists libertarians and all the
rest so we have a crisis of governance
in the face of an increasingly difficult
and dangerous world and people are upset
and I have to tell you the the
campaign's in the candidacies are not
all that inspiring but it's very
difficult to be inspiring in the midst
of this kind of challenging complexity
so I symbolize for the candidates and I
would just say they're gonna have to do
better to win the support of the
American people now some are saying that
California's primary could be the
Republicans last stand the
establishments last stand in preventing
Donald Trump from winning the nomination
is is that nomination inevitable no it's
not inevitable mr. Trump doesn't have a
majority like everything else
things happen in unpredictable ways he's
doing remarkably well but it's not he
doesn't have a majority so there's a lot
to be stay tuned there's much more to
happen I certainly wouldn't want to
predict what's gonna happen in
California it's very open
I'd say anybody can win this thing does
it scare you though that he's that close
to the nomination and and and thus to
the presidency
well I don't like to say I'm scared by
these candidates there's a lot of things
I'm more concerned about I'm concerned
about the big issues facing America and
the inability of the Republican and
Democratic leadership to get together
whether it's on a Supreme Court nominee
whether it's the finance of roads and
bridges
whether it's increase our research and
development or if it's the deal with the
the negative consequences of
globalization in the form of inequality
I'd like that to happen the president
with all the hoopla is going to
disappoint people
because if we have a dysfunctional
Congress ultimately people are gonna get
mad at the president and so I think it's
we're all in this together and I
certainly like to do Mike my part to
make it more positive political
environment who are you supporting I'm
less worried by at this point if would
you accept a VP nomination I have an
offer one I don't accept what I have no
would you be interested not particularly
why not well because I'm running for
president not vice-versa
how do you see the race playing out them
I don't predict I'm not a juice off of
your I'd say you see it demise I'd see
it was very strong and I'd say the
Republican Party hasn't quite gelled yet
but it's getting close to shelling jelly
ground Trump where it just well it's
getting close to gelling so you know
events happen to politics
scandals occur untoward events comments
made and you never I mean it is look
like it's shaping up into I mean it
looks like it's coming together but I am
a bit longer before we try to lock
things down say now we know who the
nominees are right I give us a few more
months it's Donald Trump fit to be
President
yeah I would say the idea that he's
gonna build a wall and make Mexico pay
for it is absolutely preposterous and
would create such tension where their
closest neighbor that probably a dumber
idea I can't imagine or maybe a de Namur
game that's its dumber than it is
dangerous